Hello,
and welcome back to the Rawkode Academy.
This is Thursday,
which means today is clustered.
Today, we have
two teams joining us with some broken clusters
and the hopefully successful attempt to affect both
of them and share some wonderful Kubernetes knowledge
along the way.
Before we get started, we have a few
thank yous to give and some housekeeping.
I wanna thank Teleport.
As I say every single week on clustered,
we have been using Teleport from the very
beginning. It's such an amazing product, and you're
gonna see us use it for the next
hour and a half to fix some Kubernetes
cluster in a collab collaborative
pairing
way. Go to rockode.liveteleport
because it keeps their sponsors happy and makes
it possible to keep doing cluster. So please
check them out.
And plus who doesn't want to access all
those Linux servers using
not SSH,
but get help authentication,
which is pretty special. So
alright. Next up, we have a oh,
there we go.
See, I go away for one week to
KubeCon and I forget how everything worked. I
was the one that's like Xbox metal. They
have provided the hardware for every single episode
of cluster. We don't use VMs. We use
bare metal machines with 48 cores, 96 gig
of RAM, a whole bunch of 10 gig
networking cards.
It just makes it more fun for me
and everyone else. So to say thank you
to Equinix Metal and to try it for
yourself, go to Rawkode.live/metal
and use the code Rawkode. This will get
you 200 USD in credit, which means you
can get around one hundred hours of compute
on their smallest instance. And by the way,
their small instance is not that small.
It's still a sizable machine, so go check
it out.
Okay. Let's see. We're gonna introduce our first
team today.
Team.
Hey,
all. How are you doing?
Fine. How are you? Well,
thank you all for joining me today. Let's
start with a quick round of introductions
and then we'll get started on today's first
cluster.
Hello, Rawkode.
Yeah. Hi, everyone. This is Ibrahim.
I'm working at Nissan.
So great to see you all.
Thank you.
Hi. This is Bharat,
and I'm working in a Nissan
as a DevOps engineer,
and I'm loving my job.
Thank you.
So this is Rasa. I've been I'm also
working at Nissan in the same team as
Fahad and Ebrahim
does, and we usually work with a lot
of Kubernetes clusters in the past
year or so. And so we are quite
excited to see what's in the IBM cluster
that we are gonna be fixing.
Awesome. Thank you all. I'm assuming you typically
work with working clusters. Right?
So this will be a little bit of
fun. Alright.
I'm gonna give you access to the IBM
clusters.
So I'm gonna pop open my screen share
now. I'm gonna go to team
and roles where I modify
the Nissan team.
And instead of your own cluster,
I'm gonna give you carte blanche and you
can now access everything.
On the command line, I will open a
session to IBM control plane one.
Once this opens, you will be able to
see it under active sessions on Teleport, which
is here. There we go. Please join a
session. Type some sort of command so that
I know you're there, and then we'll get
this thing underway.
I will also join from the web in
case I need it.
I can see that Carlos from the IBM
team is also in the chat. So there
we go.
Alright. We got one,
two,
hopefully a third.
But
feel free to export your KubeConfig, check for
a control plane and upgrade a cluster or
at least an application. Best of luck.
That is equals to a t c Kubernetes
admin dot com.
Kubectl.
Hopefully,
this works. Kubectl.
Yeah. Okay. It looks
good.
Seems
You have no control plan. I see.
This
is localhost
8080. Well,
this shouldn't be the case. E t c
kubernetes
admin dot com.
And here looking at the server, it says
6443.
So there's something indeed wrong with the Kube
CTL.
Yeah. It shouldn't have been going to the
localhost CTLT for the first time. Well, here
it comes. Install hyphen You're not going to
take a look at it first? You're just
gonna blow over the top of it?
Yeah. We can surely take a look.
Alias, it could be an alias too. Oh,
here you go.
Good catch. Okay. Let's
let's just check with me.
We know other teams do it and that
this team has run.
You can also run an an alias if
you want to remove it from your session
too.
And Carlos on the chat says, boo. He's
not happy that you found that so quickly.
So if we even thought we can see
the
database running, and there's the deployment as zero.
So
Yeah.
Should I try updating the replica now?
Yes. Yes. That might be that.
Interesting.
New as
STD in input output error.
First,
can you describe it first?
Describe it, sir.
I have deploy
clustered.
There's one revision.
Select
Replicas.
Set labels
here.
We haven't created any replicas. So it is
zero.
Zero desired, zero updated, zero and zero.
You're trying to edit again.
The thing that interests me is, like, why
are we not able to edit this here?
How about we get the YAML and try
to reapply it again? Would that work? Yeah.
Apply clustered.
Demo.
Clustered
deploy.
Got my ML.
Yeah. That's Here you can see that the
replicas are set to zero.
Mhmm.
And
apply hyphen f.
Let's not deploy.
Let's deploy.
It's still set to
interesting. I love it when that happens.
So so okay. So as it tried to
even here, you can see that it scaled
the replica set to one,
but then there's something fishy happening around that
is causing the replica set to reset to
zero again. Maybe there's Yeah. Must can you
check any service?
Or jobs? It might be any job. Yeah.
Here it is. The scale deployment set to
zero. Uh-huh. Yeah. Interesting. Still
Still that. Yeah.
The only thing is could it be in
the current tab that could cause it to
fail? Like, let's just see if it gets
created again.
So here you can see that the process
started again. So
contab hyphen e, could it be there? No.
Contab for
use an n using an empty one.
So,
David, like, we are not able to open
the demo or something like an editor.
I'm assuming that's a break.
Yeah. So
one But it So,
Nasir, can you check service is running with
some another user?
I can't exit it, like
Yeah. Yeah.
There
we go. Control d. Okay. So if you
look
It's a break, and I know what it
yeah. You got it. You got That is
equals to VIM. So e q. Good job
whoever did that.
Wow.
Okay. So that was a good thing to
do.
System
CTL. It could be a system retimer.
That is
we can search for something like
a cube CTL.
Any process has been running. So here you
can see that there's this cube for the
separate.
Yeah. Interesting.
This sounds a little interesting. What's this?
This is an e b p f filter
that is running,
and this cube.
Is this a pod?
PostgresQL,
cube resolver.
There's something fishy going around with the cube
resolver as well.
Fourteen hours, fourteen hours, core DNS is messed
up as well.
CoreDNS
is messed up as well.
Any ideas, folks? Ebrahim or Fad?
Let
me see. First
of all, I get, like, some service system
deservice,
but
it doesn't look like so.
Well, just to clarify. Right? You've you've found
a process on a process table that is
doing the bad thing. So how how can
you get us payment?
Pardon me. What did you say? We got
the process back? Yeah. If you do do
your p s command again with kubectl. The
correct p.
So you you've got you've got a process
here.
Mhmm. Yeah. What you wanna do is is
find this parent. You're trying to work out
how it's being scheduled.
There's also something very interesting about this process.
Even from what we can see right now.
I'll give you a minute before.
Minus. We see
Hey, Nasir. Can you check the
user file, the shadow file? Yeah. Good belongs
to one double zero one
and check the Chrome tab for that
user. Sorry, Fahad. Can you please share the
command again? Pass yeah. Pass w d. ETC
pass w d.
ETC pass w d.
Yeah. There's different user, basically. One double o
one. First one double o one. Yeah.
No user found, I don't think.
Okay.
Sorry. Okay.
Can you check with the front tab for
for that user, actually, the one double z
y? K. I think we're just not done
with the user ID as well.
How do we do that?
Oh,
can you can you switch that user
with the ID? S u one double zero
one?
Yeah.
So
one I use it now.
That user doesn't exist in there.
What
might be the issue?
Address. Because, like, I could see that in
system CTL status.
So it could be a container. Yep.
That that has the user ID 1Double01.
Mhmm.
Let's see if
this guy has something.
Queue scheduler.
No. DNS.
Is a container because the user is, 1Double01
and the user is not on the main
system.
It is inside a container, but we are
not really sure which container is it.
Yeah. If the user resolved on your p
s command, you would see the username rather
than the number. So it doesn't resolve to
an active user, but you're looking for the
parent process
so you can work out how to kill
this thing persistently.
So there's flags you can pass to p
s or you could use a proc fail
system.
Press props.
And the process ID is 415284.
4 1 4. Yeah.
This is interesting.
Fax session ID, net maps,
limits,
c m d line. Go ahead and filter.
What
is this route here?
Root is CWD.
CWD
and there's this x z?
Oh, I got into the container?
Could it be that
more hyphen a u I?
This
is the process inside this one. So
two hyphen
nine.
Just check the name.
U x
I didn't know you could get into containers
like this as well.
To see Are you in a container or
are you on a namespace? I mean
mean,
it's a thin line. A thin line, but
still
like, mean, from what we see in the
CryoControl, I don't think you're necessarily in what
we would call, like, a complete container. But
Just checking, like, the
front tab and the
front tab has any no
contact. Contact.
Yeah.
This is a Linux namespace.
Okay. So you have some namespaces,
but you still have access to system d,
which means you still have access to some
of the host namespaces.
Take a look at the status file and
the proc file system.
Status
Yeah. Cat proc p I d status.
Cat proc
p I d.
I think the process changed as I build
it from
Uh-huh. The inside.
And a good tip from Nolan in chat
as well. Taking a look at the command
line fail will also reveal some useful stuff.
But I would start with data.
So cat
block 418291
and
pressure
two nine one. And what should I do
afterwards?
Status.
Status. Okay.
This
is log data.
SH,
your mask,
0022.
You see the p p it?
P p I. Yeah. Right. Yeah. So that's
your payment process. We know you could start
to track that.
61856.
Oh, parent process.
Yeah.
Yeah. That's 618
56.
6.
Interesting. Container d and some namespace.
This is a container. It is a container.
Yeah.
Yeah. So
c I o c t l might might
not do that. There's this container d c
l I, if I could recall it properly.
So container d c l I won't help
you here. You can use CTR or control.
I
don't wanna give too much away because you're
doing really well. But if you wanna hand,
I'll give you one.
C t r hyphen hyphen help container
d c l I
containers.
C
t r.
C t r. My bad.
C t r containers
l s.
Have you used the c t r command
before?
No. Alright. So everything in the everything running
in Kubernetes lives in a namespace called k.
Okay. Minus add, like,
minus n k.
Well, that would show you the Kate's namespace.
Yeah.
Do you think this is in the Kate's
namespace?
Oh,
sorry.
I didn't get the command properly.
So you'll you'll have to put the dash
and kits before
l s, I think. Maybe even before containers.
I don't recall it.
Correct. I don't remember exactly. Dash sounds
interesting to do You can just c l
s instead of containers l. It's up to
you.
Okay. C l s. C space l s.
Sorry.
Yes. It's sometimes my advice is bad. Yes.
So that's your case
namespace, but there could be others.
Okay.
C t r.
How do we get all the namespaces then?
The namespaces Yeah. Mean, s
Namespaces.
N sls. L s.
K t s l I 0 and and
default. So we can have, like in both
of these, there could be IO.
Okay.
There's two VIP.
All of it looks
quite so, yeah, here's the container that is
running, docker dot io bitnami with the kubectl,
and this is the container ID.
So hopefully, I think we might be able
to kill it from here. Yeah. I think
you've got it. Well done.
Hyphen n,
it's dot I o.
Oh,
the thing works like that. It's delete. It's
The namespace.
Cannot delete a nonstop container. So you've I
think you've got to stop it first.
Stop.
Let's see. Sorry. Let's see.
Stop there.
There's no stop there.
I believe the delete slash r m command
does take an extra parameter. Stop.
Okay.
Delete.
When I got the help for
delete, so let's just get that c t
r c delete
hyphen hyphen help.
Oh, I thought it was a dash f.
Maybe there's something amongst
in the CTRC
command,
like, that could
somehow put into, like, stop a container,
delete Yeah. CTR it is CTR
task
l s you can do and kill that
task.
CTR task l s.
Namespace. Dot
I o. Uh-oh.
This is,
I've been in the habit of writing the
namespace in the end, and this always leads
up to bad stuff. Uh-oh.
This doesn't feel
so here's the task, Ebrahim. And how
do we get the task of
so here's the container ID.
Yeah. So how do I stop this?
Yeah. You can do basically
CTR task kill
and
the word missing the ID.
Today I learned. CTR. Good tip.
Nice. C l s.
I could still see the container here, so
should I now try to delete the container?
Yeah. Just write.
And not delete a nonstop container.
I
stop how do we stop a container
in C t r c l I? Can
we try some task
kill
that task? We
tried killing the task, but it still seems
that
You
you tried to remove.
You should kill the task.
Like,
this is how we did that. Like, c
t I hyphen n task kill. Oh, okay.
And you tried. Okay. Okay. And then
that didn't end up really well.
Uh-huh.
So
I just wanna throw something out there. I
mean, there there in my head, it feels
like there's two options. Like, either Carlos has
been very sneaky
and run a container in the case IO
namespace
outside of Kubernetes.
But this
I mean, it came back after the test
call. Maybe it's scheduled via Kubernetes and we
missed it.
I don't know. But
it could be there.
It
should be a part, I believe, in order
to oh, it could be a con job
or job as well.
Yeah. Job was, like, a con job that
is running, like, intermittently.
No.
No. There's MSA, there's HCD,
IBM,
there's the cube resolver that is failing every
that thirty eight minutes ago.
I think we could take a look at
the hints. Oh, you don't need the hints.
You're so close.
I mean, are are you familiar with the
cluster dump command that allows you to view
all the container images?
Like, that could be useful right now.
Cluster dump command.
Kubectl
cluster
info
cluster dash info space dump,
I think.
So that's everything you need to know about
this cluster. And I suspect if you were
to grab that, uh-huh, for Bitnami or a
kubectl, you might find something interesting.
Maybe go for Bitnami. Yeah.
Here's something that's Bitnami,
and it says that the last apply it
is a deployment
with the name of
labels that has Selium. Name is Selium operator.
No. Not this one. There's this API metadata
annotations.
Name is core DNS. So the core DNS
port somehow seems to be running this.
There's, like, the core DNS pod which is
running this command instead of Let's take a
look. DNS
interesting.
Kubectl
get pods hyphen
pods hyphen
n cube system.
And if you would add it to the
edit
to the where's it going in this one?
Yeah. This is fourteen hours ago. So there's
one running fifteen hours and there's one running
fourteen hours ago. That calls for some suspicion.
Mhmm. Code DNS. Oh, port.
Not
all pods. Pod
yeah.
I hate this.
Code
editor.
VIM.
Why is it still defaulting to EQ?
Kubectl
editor. There's a way to set in kubectl
editor?
Mean, you could just do a get dash
o yamo for now until you need to
modify it. But, yeah, I'm not sure what
sneaky thing he's done to break that there.
He has done something.
That sounds good. Complex
thing, I think so.
Oh, but
And Just get system.
Yeah.
Yeah. I think your grip led you down
a bad path there because you were missing
one flag for full context.
Try adding a dash b 10
to your grip.
We should give you 10 layers before the
match as well. So I I think what
happened is
on your grip. Sorry.
There's a cluster info dump grip.
Cluster info
and
give c t l.
Cluster rental,
dump
wrap.
Grab. Uh-oh.
Cube CTL
hyphen b 10. Yeah. Done.
No space, and I can't remember if it's
a capital b or not. You'll need yeah.
There you go.
But search for Vietnam instead of Cube Control.
I think that'll make your life a bit
easier.
But, yeah, let's just do that.
Because kubectrol, you're getting all the clients that
apply stuff as well.
Then that is running
the metadata.
No. We're not gonna continue. Look at the
double dash here. Again, we're being misled because
we don't have enough back buffer. So increase
the 10 a little bit more.
You you get there in a minute. Try
it. Yeah. Try 15.
Try 50.
50.
We want that fill JSON context there. Right?
So you've got your bitnami image here. Let's
just follow-up. I'm
trying to see what's the
name of the container status. There you go.
You got it now. It's there now if
you see it. The improved resolver ID.
Just go. Yeah.
Rick, I am it
But just to just jiggle the size a
tiny little bit, and it should help.
Or you can type reset on the CLI,
which will also help.
Okay. Yeah. Right now.
So
what we did was we get we got
the. What was the name of the container
or the pod? I wasn't able to look
at that properly.
It was the cube resolver. Yeah.
Cube resolver.
Just go again and just cross check it.
Kube system. Like, if it's Kube Resolver, then
it should be
a static part. So I will
is the
Kubernetes manifest,
you resolve
where there's nothing like this here.
The the core name, the cube resolver one.
Cube resolver and the whole thing one, I
think. So that's
having something
with it. But having
this in the end, IBM
control plane one, this calls for, like, it
could it should be a
static
port,
but, like, it could be something that's, like,
kept inside
any of these files because, like, the kubelet's
just gonna
run and see for this.
We could search for something like code d
resolver.
It could also just be a pod.
Can
you just
check it while
deleting it? Scratch a pod?
Can you remove it? I
yeah. It will create, I think so. Let
let's just quickly see if it's the place.
Yeah. This is the one, so I could
try deleting it.
Yeah. Click CTL delete
pod
hyphen n gube system.
I think that was a a code break
from Carlos because it looks like a static
pod, but it's not a static pod. It
looks like a real control plane component, but
it's not a real control plane component.
And this came back, so it was not
just the pod, which is also a fun
mystery.
So And this is a fun mystery. Like,
we can look at the
if something is applying
this cube resolver. Can you do,
Rasu, can you do cube CTL get all
on namespace cube system?
Yeah.
Okay. So
the logs
Should we try getting the logs of
cubelet?
This is a cool comment from Russell on
the chat. Journal sheet.
YAML fails can contain more than one definition,
can't they?
I was thinking
about
Yeah. You you had to tag it and
then didn't do the grip, but I was
I was surprised. You were so close. I
mean, assuming we're right, which we don't know.
Good.
So
here we have Fahad, who is, like, our
Linux, like, these utilities experts. So, Fahad, what
would be the flag to get the
con search the content in constant sorry, content
inside the file?
Like, I want to search for something that
could be in any of these profiles.
Yeah. You can search for anything and
so
you are trying to find anything in all
the files?
If you want to list the files like
as a dash l.
Yep. Hyphen l and then dot? Nope. And
then you'll do resolver space star.
Resolver.
Space. Yep. Resolver. Dash l
should show the space star, not dash star.
Okay.
Not there.
There's nothing.
So I am thinking that it could be
the cubelet being fishy, and then there's another
flag which,
like, which would get it to run
static ports from some other location as well.
Cubelet.
And
here, you should see.
I don't see anything.
Is this? This sounds fishy like c s
n 10 up. This seems like
someone
messed up with this Kubelet file.
And,
let me just read the file. If you'd
open the file, this is the container. So
it is the kubelet.
Very cool stuff. Yeah.
So where do we get system CTL?
Edit kubelet?
Where? Where
do we have the kubelet configuration file?
The system
Var lab kubelet slash config dot YAML.
Var lab
kubelet slash
uh-huh.
PEM config
dot yaml.
And there there should be a flag as
manifest.
It's not
too good.
Can we But, like can we
install the utility and
bypass this error, I think so.
Which utility?
The cube CTL utility.
There's
this is this seems to be not a
KubeCTL
issue, but something on the Kubelet level.
Like, whenever the Kubelet is starting, there is
this manifest URL,
which causes to run this additional pod. And
in the pod, if you would visit this
URL,
you are gonna see the definition the pod
definition
to
the manifest URL flag. And then if you
do open that, you are gonna see that
it's a pod which is running kubectl
run,
like
Mhmm. Scale the deployment back to zero again.
Very good. So it is, like, the system
d service.
This
like, I would have to reset it again.
Yeah.
Uh-huh. So it does something
with the
system d service.
If you see system So your your best
command for that is system control
cat and then the service name. It will
show you everything you need to know.
Yeah.
Cat.
And in that, we could search for a
kubelet. Mhmm.
So this is the thing environment.
Okay. Good job whoever did this.
And
this
was quite
is really fishy.
And the kubelet, it added bootstrap kubelet.com,
kubelet configures,
and then I'm gonna just close
this one out. Right? And
it had only this. Yeah. Yeah. Will be
for it. It should get back to blitz
system CTLs.
Restart.
Restart it as right. You blitz
system CTO,
I was telling the same thing to,
like, yesterday
when he made the same mistake, and now
I'm doing the same thing here.
But and,
wow. It seems like, it should be reset.
Yeah.
CTL. Yes.
System CTL, daemon reload, system uh-oh.
System CTL
restart.
Kubelet.
Yes.
P s hyphen a u x. I don't
still trust that thing, so I would need
the kubelet.
Good god. Who? Yeah.
It's it's
well,
Kubectl get deploy.
So
I think I got the deployment
in the root location.
Clusterdeploy.tml.
So I should think I should just,
uh-oh, just like Yeah. Yeah. Every time.
If CTL apply hyphen f,
cluster deploy.ym
l. And hopefully,
this wouldn't
It is taking too much time. Weird.
Operation cannot be filtered.
Okay. You can
deploy hyphen l clustered.
And
then place it to clusterdeploy.Lima.
Uh-oh. Not this one.
Instead of solving, why do we why are
we not able to run WIM? We are
just, like, taking another path rather than trying
to solve the whole thing
That is and we could
set the replica count to be one.
There's something messy with core DNS as well.
I feel that, so we are gonna probably
see that later.
Right after this,
and we still don't You have not applied
it yet.
Ah, okay. This is, like, the
trying to fix something and then just trying
to see well, it should have trying deploy.
Uh-huh. Very well done. Yeah. They should get
that. And, hopefully, I would I see it.
Well,
I think
the pod is still there, and I would
have to now kill the pod again. Also,
the cubelet is restarted. There could be a
copy of the pod in the HCD.
So let's just try getting the pod again.
Update the hints.
Yeah. We've got five minutes left. I don't
know how many more breaks we have.
I thought we were close, but then Carlos
has also said, I think I did too
many break. So
Okay.
Let's just check for hint
view.
And the alias as RC can be best
to start. Okay. That there's something that we
You have fixed that. Yep.
Yeah.
Hint one. Can you There's hint one.
I can't see the hint now because, like,
I'll have to reset it.
Weird.
Super weird. Hint one.
The perky type those perky typos don't let
us resolve DNS.
Okay. That is that was something that was
expecting the
what is the issue to
how many core DNS ports do you really
need?
No. That's, like But there's
that is something that is not related to
us yet as well? Yeah. Yeah.
I will check the rest of the hands
and see if you can find anything related
to this respawning
process.
And quickly, like, do this one thing and
try killing the pod again because I still
feel
cube scheduler?
What what was it? Cube resolver. Resolver. That's
what resolver, it is gone. It's not there
anymore. Yeah. Oh. Yeah.
That is interesting.
How many okay. Cube, c t a, kubelet
k. We fixed this one as well.
A typo is always typo always miss an
endpoint.
I think looking at the current setup,
like,
the score DNS, these two, and I feel
like there's something wrong going around with this.
Okay. So as our deployment scales back to
zero, that's what I'm curious about at the
moment.
We get deployed.
Tube CTL get deploy.
Yeah. It scaled back to zero.
I
could try, like, searching for
tube CTL again in case there's something running
in the background.
There's nothing that's causing it to behave like
this.
There's something wrong with the controller manager.
It had a restart Kubernetes
manifest.
You have controller manager.
Could it be that there's a flag?
Entry level manager
system CTL.
It looks
good.
It does indeed.
Can you check, like, cube config is going
for right path?
It is That's correct. Kubernetes into manager. Yeah.
Manager.
Do we have any do. Sorry?
Well, one of the hands told you to
look at the core DNS deployment. Are those
both really core DNS?
Kubectl
get deploy.
Perfect. Cube the code DNS runs as a
deploy. Right? Okay.
And I so is it just So one
on one. Not able to see?
So on one on one. Like, can you
go for, like, check the ports, patch ports
of cube system?
Oh, yeah. I can't, like, do anything because
the
so what should I do? Sorry. If you
resize your browser, it will fix that.
Okay. Let's see. Get pods.
Get pods hyphen e?
No. Yeah.
Can you do it? Yeah. So there's two
core DNS there, and your deployment was set
to one. Just kill kill the both one.
Kill the both. Yeah.
So delete bot
and code DNS code
DNS hyphen
n
coop system.
I guess what you're hoping for with that
is that one doesn't come back. Right?
Yeah.
Cube system.
And Ebrahim, you were indeed right. There's something
fishy. And I think while doing this, I
broke the controller manager.
Have you done any changes on that?
I am not really sure because what happened
was I wasn't able to see something.
Why didn't you you have that you don't
have done anything
wrong with it.
Okay.
Why is it getting in the error now?
Describe
pod.
Okay. There was the code DNS pod running
the same thing as well. So if you
would
scale it now, kubectl apply hyphen f cluster
deploy.
Well, you don't have a controller manager.
Yeah.
That
sounds
Which may be an issue.
Seems to be the opposite.
Tube system.
Not sure what caused it to go wrong.
Why is it killing the pod?
It says the pod sandbox changed.
The host that to the only one.
Created container,
stop started container, and then stop container. Yes.
Hyphen a u x. There I see, like,
there's some there could be something fishy causing
this to happen.
The controller
manager,
the VIP, the scheduler.
There's HDD running. There's QA server.
There's QA manager.
I think we could refer to the hints
one more time and see what's the those
spiky typos don't lesser let us resolve DNS.
I think what happened here is
when you were messing around with the profile
system and entered,
you probably entered the controller manager, which was
responsible for starting the manifest URL pod.
I think if you force delete
or restart the kubelet, you may get it
working again.
But that's a speculation.
We restarted the kubelet. Also, I feel like
the
deleting the pod with force, so that should
do that. That should do it, like, getting
this pod
and
hyphen n cube system.
Uh-oh. Delete pod. Pod.
Pod.
Okay.
Cube controller
manager.
It can take up to four minutes unless
you restart the kubelet.
Okay. Let's just do that. System CTL
restart kubelet,
and
it should
come up.
Interesting.
Maybe
it is, like, looking at the file and
to see if there's something that got changed.
Yeah. You you can add a blank lane
if you want.
When
hyphen hyphen.
So should I just, like, add a Yeah.
Just add a black line to the bottom
and save it. Let's see what happens.
And try your get pods one more time.
Fresh loopback.
Why does that loopback
I
think this is related to the DNS itself.
Describe pod hyphen n same. Namespace.
Hyphen n cube system.
And what's the image that it's running?
That is correct. Code in
that is correct.
Could it be the case that someone has,
like, over at the gates.gcr.i0
to be
to, like, point to some other registry?
I don't think so. I the hints never
alluded to that, and I don't think Carlos
would have us chasing down something that's not
correct.
I'm a bit concerned about the controller manager
not coming back. I don't think that is
intentional.
Carlos, if you wanna just jump on the
link though, we can walk us through the
the last step or to to fix this.
Yeah.
Because I feel like these are so close.
They use a used a work through so
many amazing problems here. So
let's see what Carlos says. Yeah.
I didn't think that was intentional, Carlos, he
said.
I think that was the the entering the
name space and doing the kill is that
we we probably made that control manager broken
by ourselves.
That
was weird. Like, I updated the I just
opened it and then closed that, and then
it didn't let the controller manager come up
again. That's, like,
weird.
So Carlos would be jumping on the call.
Right? Oh, yeah. He'll be here in a
second.
I assume.
There's a link in your email, Carlos. Come
on. Pay attention.
Alright. Let's I'm gonna just poke it already
because I I'm super curious myself. Right? Oh,
control
pod.
We have a controller manager running, which is
good. Our core DNS is definitely broken, but
I don't care about core DNS actually.
I think we were I think we were
just maybe very impatient there. You've got this
cluster deployment and the root directory. Right? So
let's reapply that, which I think will get
you your pod.
Try again. Now you'll have to. Oh, you're
gonna have to do it again, aren't I?
Okay.
Yeah. D.
It's not there.
Yeah. Deployment.
Deploy at n o
at the end the email.
That's about it.
Alright.
And we're gonna get pods.
That's surprising.
There's
no application set at all. I haven't I
haven't edited the the KL file. Right? So
Oh, you didn't update that. Yeah.
Yeah.
And we will reapply that one more time,
plus Carlos has just joined. So
what's that? Apply.
Oh, come on. Yeah.
Yes.
You could update that. Yeah. There you go.
So now
r f pods.
Right. Now you got a different number.
But we are out of time, so I'm
gonna bring Carlos in.
Hey, evil person. Hey, Carlos. Hi,
Carlos.
So I think I'm hearing too. Yeah. We
can hear you. Can you hear me? Yeah.
Yeah. Okay. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
So, yeah, controller controller manager wasn't wasn't planned.
So how do you fix that?
We waited. And you apply the
sorry? We just waited, and the controller manager
had to come back after Yeah. Yeah. The
forced delete and the restart. What's the error
now? Or image pool? Yeah. Image pool on
a clustered application.
And, yeah, do a describe on that.
What's wrong.
So, yeah, I I you you fixed the
two the two things that did the scale
to zero. So this one is sending telling
you that fail to put image to GCR,
fail to request head,
look up HTML.
Oh, yes. They can't look at GCR. That's
inside DNS.
Yeah. DCP. So it cannot look GCR dot
I o. So do you have a DNS
issue?
I see config map. Yeah. CoreDNS
hyphen system.
So the the this config map
for CoreDNS
should look okay.
But
Well, we can't edit any files. How did
you do that?
Yeah. Sorry? We can't use kubectl edit. How
did you break that?
Oh, it's a global profile.
Export export kubectl editor equals vim. It's an
environment called cube add cube underscore editor. Don't
like that. Yeah.
So Yeah. This this this looks correct. So
the the break was I messed up with
the DNS on the
on the workers.
Oh, okay. Oh,
interesting.
Wait one.
That's a good one.
Oh, you used the two workers. I don't
know how I managed that. I must have
broke my automation again.
Sorry for too many breaks.
It should it should have stopped there. So
this one looks correct, but this is not
the real one, right,
in Ubuntu.
So the real one resolver?
Yep. Exactly.
I have to remember where that lives. So
that's It's the slash system
cache. Resolve.com. Resolve
Com.
Oh, yeah.
DNS is zero zero zero the DNS
and fell back, and DNS equals zero zero
zero is wrong.
Yeah.
Alright. Let's
leave it there.
I I think you
said I I thought that the scale to
zero was going to be, like, quick. Right?
We're going to get into this one. So
good job. Good job.
Alright. Well, we don't have time to fix
the DNS and work through that, but I
think that was the last thing. I think
you just did a really good job. Like,
you just played through a lot of breaks
there. And Carlos
is very, very sneaky. Yeah. There's a
I see that. Yeah. I I I did
a, like, a silly thing. I I applied
this the this the same break twice.
Right? Scale to zero with two different pods.
He didn't. Alright. It was, like, fun to
solve that because, like, at first when we
deleted the first one, I thought the process
is over, but then there was doing
the same sneaky thing again.
So, yeah, that was a quite interesting to
look at.
Alright. Well, let's see what needs to have
in store for Carlos. Well, thank you for
joining me. Feel free to watch the rest
and join the comments on YouTube, and thank
you again for for working for that. You've
done very well.
Alright. Let's pop over here. Let's move Carlos
to here,
and let's get you access
to
the other cluster. While I do that, do
you wanna just introduce yourself for anyone that
is not familiar with you, please?
Yeah.
I am a principal engineer in IBM,
work with OpenShift and
DevOps assets for IBM middleware and also upstream.
I do upstream Kubernetes with sick release,
Kubernetes office hours, and Knative.
Alright. Thank you. Well, you now have access
to every machine.
I'm gonna share my screen now, and I'm
gonna open a control play open an SSH
session. SSH
session
to our Nissan
control plane. And I'll just pop
these off. There we go.
Alright. So session is open. Please feel free
to export your cube config,
and best of luck, Carlos.
Hey. You're not bearing with me
by myself?
No. No. I'm here. I'm here. Pleasure to
work.
So I think I'm in the right one.
Crossover playing. Russell's saying, good luck team IBM,
or is it just Carlos? Unfortunately, Carlos's teammate
is unwell.
So I am team Carlos today or team
boot camp as we're gonna call it.
So did it work? I put echo Carlos.
Did it show up? Nope. You've opened your
own session instead of joining mine, I think.
So
I need to go to sessions. Sessions. Yep.
And then the bottom one should be my
session or at least the one that says
Rawkode. I
don't see that here. See clusters,
activity,
ah, activity, active sessions, and then which one?
The Rawkode one.
Here is
The one that says Rawkode right here, if
you can see my screen and my IP
address.
Yeah.
Awesome.
You are in.
I mean, you're you know what you're doing.
I'll I'll be there if you need that,
but go for it, man.
Okay. So
I have to keep keep CTL.
Okay. Finally,
I keep CTL.
So keep
Well, we already have the cluster
running
in the pod. Sorry. I have activated hacker
mode on your background since you've got a
green screen set there. Oh,
thanks.
Yeah. I couldn't figure out the the thing.
I'm doing the the things. Okay.
So the body scratch look back. Let me
do something because I'm
I'm OCD on this. I use
k.
Epsityl
completion.
Completion bash,
and then you'll need to Yeah.
You just I'm lazy, so I was, like,
get it from here.
Why it doesn't have autocomplete in tab?
What's wrong with this?
You don't have auto we don't they break
auto complete?
It's normally auto complete.
I thought I had auto complete on mine.
I mean, crazy. Okay.
Sorry about that.
It's like it just just
I'm not That is a lot of restarts.
Yeah. Let's see what's going on.
Logs.
Prescribe.
Failed
container. Putting image.
So it's backup Failed to create container. The
task to create shim. OCI runtime create
fail. Run c create fail. Unable to start
container process.
Error doing container in need. Error setting c
group. Config for prod hooks process. Unable to
set memory limit.
Current usage.
Peak usage.
Unknown.
They messed up with the
with
the container d
around c.
I think that's
Is that a question, or are you talking
to yourself? I wasn't sure.
Oh, no. I'm
just talking to myself.
So
I think it's just could not
start this because of some something with
run c
create failed.
Yeah. It says error settings c group config
for process
unable to set the memory limit to this
value.
Oh.
But the memory limits
are fine. Five m one m one.
I mean, does the machine have enough memory?
I don't know. Maybe maybe they mess up
with the
nodes.
Didn't say anything about the note.
Oh, the
notes.
Not even being sched did it get scheduled?
K. It was scheduled. Yes.
On which node
to say here?
No. You'll need to get pods or wait.
Oh, because there's a pod. Okay. Yeah.
Worker one.
Yeah. I'm not sure how I managed to
revert my automation to give you two worker
nodes. I need to revert
that.
Does anyone want get two worker nodes? I
only get one worker node. Oh, yeah. But
that rebase went wrong somewhere.
K.
Join us so I can see VIM.
Conditions.
You don't see VIM in your end? Oh,
I've just joined the wrong session. That's all.
Don't worry about me.
It's done for me.
It's running. The the pressure, pods,
capacity.
Memory.
Yeah. It's fine. The capacity.
Yep. We have 48 CPUs and 65 gig
of RAM. Yeah.
Pretty big. Right?
Yeah. Not too bad. Nice bare metal. What
is current metal. Plug, plug, plug.
I
oh, that I've hinted in here. So
should we check
what how do we check the the run
c configuration?
At c system?
Why run c? Question for you.
Well, the error says something about the run
c cannot create because cannot allocate the c
group.
So maybe
So I would be checking the kubelet config
or the container d config if one happens
to exist.
The TOML from container ID. Let's check kubelet.
But we'll have to jump on to worker
one then for that. Right?
Yeah.
So how do we do that from the
GUI session?
Yep. I'll just open a new one there.
A new session should be there
entirely.
There you go. I see. Yep. I see
something here.
This one.
Worker
one.
Right?
You see that? Yeah. Yep. Yep. We're good.
So, yeah, kubelet and container d is what
you wanna check.
The plug in is not on this one.
Right?
Duration.
Let me see if I see something funky
here.
That looks clean.
Looks clean.
Let's see.
And the
other one any other
configuration?
Well, there's the QB It's on the plugins.
No?
The plugin is not where it gets configured.
No. Right?
Why
not try container d config dump and see
if that's best of anything?
Container
d what? Space config space dump,
which will tell you if there's a custom
container d config, of which there is not.
Generated file to load Tomo. So that's not
the one that's using? That just means that
container d is not configured. That's the default
set at the box, so we don't need
to worry about that.
So let's check system
control cat
kubelet and see if there's two other locations
that they can modify the kubelet.
So we've got over here
slash
e t c slash default slash kubelet, and
we have the kubelet and flags dot e
n p.
I think that YAML
and the bootstrap kubelet.
I'm not worried about the bootstrap kubelet. I
think that's mostly just authentication stuff.
But the it's ECC default kubelet and the
Kubernetes and flags probably worth checking it.
Then we can start panicking.
Sorry. I missed what you said. How about
checking which flag?
So you see the environment file in that
cat?
There's the Environment? Varlib kubelet kubelet kubelet dash
flags dot a n b.
So we can look in that file Oh,
yeah. As the password. Yeah. To
see if there's anything in there. Yeah. And
there's also the slash e t c slash
default slash kublet, which could be modified in
some way.
Environment file. So the two
The two environment files. The two middle ones.
But the front ones. But it's using one
of them.
Right? Environment file and environment file. Like, the
variable is set is set twice. If they
get appended.
They get appended.
Yeah. It's just in both.
Okay. So let's check the first one. Yeah.
Let's do that.
Leave keep that.
Keep anything
from here.
Looks good.
Container runtime endpoint,
the sock,
and pause.
And the other one is at c
c default
to
doesn't exist.
A file doesn't exist, which I think it
might be okay. Right? Yep. That's fine if
it doesn't exist. Okay. So they're not modifying
the kubelet or container d to give us
that error message, which make this more fun.
Where where do I check container d config?
Where's that TOML that it's using? Well, if
the TOML doesn't exist, this is the default
hard coded one. So you don't have to
worry about it.
So I think let's see the error message
again.
Yeah. Let me see.
I found the work at control plane node.
And the other one.
This one. Right?
That's the one.
Why is this tiny?
My window.
Because
is
trying to resize our thing to be the
same size. Yeah. You said it earlier.
It says, network to container
the task. Failed to create shim.
OCI runtime create failed.
Runc create failed.
So I'm I want to see, like, where
is the
plugin configure.
But you said that there's no TOML for
container ID on this system
because it's using the default one.
The inner Why why are you saying plug
in? Am I missing something? Like, I don't
see anything that says plug in.
Oh, no. No. It's just just me, like,
defining, like, the cubelet using a plug in
to for for running container c
run c.
Yeah. I don't think this is run c
or container d.
Or c group related?
I mean, I'm not gonna say it's not
c groups related. I don't know. I I
have never seen this one. I've never seen
this error message before.
Interesting.
These are the memory. Right? There's no resource
range limits don't apply here. The quota doesn't
apply here. Right?
There should not be any
quotas
for resource I don't I don't think we're
dealing with quota yet. Let let's check the
container d log. I think that might be
the next best bet on the worker node.
And that's from
system
From journal control. Yeah. But on the worker,
not the control plane.
Do we want dash u container ID? I
would do f l u, make it a
bit easier to read
and follow.
F l u.
Let's see.
We got that same error message. Okay. So
container d definitely as the one that's getting
this message, which tells me because there's no
container d config,
probably something on the host.
Because that might
yeah. I don't know.
Let's try a system control cat container d
and see if there's any limits put on
the process.
System
CTL cat container d? Yeah.
Like, minutes on the on the on the
container ID process itself? Yeah. There's a there's
a couple of things here that
I'm worried about this score adjust.
See that? This one?
Let's remove that.
Remove that? Yeah. And that's located in
system Yep. You've got it. That file. System
d slash system slash container d.
The system again. So system d slash system.
Yeah.
And I'll type today.
Slash System. Internal container do there?
There's no container do here.
Where did we I mean, this thing prints
toward the location. No? The the Yeah. The
cat should oh, yeah. Sorry. Lab system d
system container d service.
Where you saw that
at the top? Oh, here it is. Yeah.
Yeah. At the top.
Lab
system
The system
here. So I think what that score adjust
is doing
is even though we've got sensible memory memory
limits, it's it's actually
augmenting them to make them appear worse than
the system actually is. I think the main
thing the thing. By putting a negative number?
Yeah. Yeah. I think. So I think if
we just delete that and go with the
infinity and everything else, we might be alright.
Just deleting it so that default should be
infinity. Right?
Yeah. Just comment out. I think that's gonna
be okay. And then we can do a
system control daemon reload and restart.
Demon.
Oh,
it's not it's then reload daemon reload. You
have to put
reload daemon. I forgot. No. No. It should
be daemon reload.
I just not don't know how to
daemon.
Yeah. I think you had it right. Does
it not work?
No. It says daemon reload. No. No.
Cannot spell.
Never mind.
CTL restart.
Continue. Said
is in the chat telling us that
the arm adjustment score with the minus nine
nine nine. I think he said it's actually
less likely to call processes, but that could
have been a complete red heading.
I'm not sure.
Okay.
So So if we run that Yeah.
Let's do get pods and see. Yarn all
again.
See the the logs?
We don't see the error in the logs.
I'll restart the pods.
Let me see. We're here. Oh, okay.
That get
that get you just did it? It's pending.
It's pending.
Pending to Still pending. Yeah. It definitely feels
too long, doesn't it? Yeah. The describe.
Alright. Now we've got a scheduling error, so
we can work with that. Right?
So it wasn't
Although, the limit for five m four. The
five m is never gonna run.
Sorry?
We've got a limit of one meg of
memory, which might be okay for this Rust
process because Rust is awesome. But I I
don't think it'll run on five m, so
we might wanna remove those limits.
Okay. But I let let us let schedule
it first. Right? I think we can fix
the schedule thing first.
Uh-huh.
Scheduling disable.
So it's taint tainted.
Did not tolerate Painted or carded. Taint.
Yeah. We can just edit the these two
guys. Right?
You could just So the other so the
other okay. So I thought it got scheduled
before before we did the container ID. But,
anyway,
would would just edit these two worker nodes.
Right? Remove the paints.
Mhmm.
No schedule.
Yep. You can delete all those things.
And that. Schedule go through?
Yeah. Delete that. That this one. Right? Yep.
Delete.
Then I will not have a spec. That's
that's alright. That's okay for notes.
Just empty object.
Oh, you could just remove that line too.
To make it a gist? I won't care.
K.
I'm I'm all CD on on YAML. Sorry.
Okay. So that should've moved better.
Much better.
But
Okay. So now we need to move that
CPU limit.
I guarantee you that run container editor is
the CPU limit.
I think so. Let's see. Yeah. For sure.
Zero three nodes. Put image. Create a container.
Successor fail to create container task.
Oh, that was an error. That's that was
the old one? No. Wait.
Let's remove the limits. We don't need them.
Our question is just to update this container.
So
There's no limits here.
Where's the container?
Here it is.
I can't see because there's probably bug, but
My bad. Are you editing or am I
editing? You're editing.
What? You jump around.
Okay. So that's it.
Let's see.
Add new pod. There we go.
Yep. We got
should be okay. We can check. Yep. We
can test. Let me pull up the
Oh, why?
Yeah. It should be
any IP on 30,000.
Right?
Connection refused.
On 30,000?
Uh-huh.
Service.
Upward.
30,000.
Doesn't work. Are we running the right image?
Yeah. Compute share issues. I was checking that.
I'm back.
And there's no logs. Right?
No. Oh, sorry. I'll I'll stop typing. Yeah.
There's no logs. My application does not log.
But but they'll fix that.
No. We have we don't have endpoints.
Oh, there we go. Yeah. Yeah. So
what's that?
I get bought.
We'll check the service selector.
So just save our service.
Yeah. Let me get
Oh, just show label. First.
And then
oh, it's crash loopback.
I bet. Oh,
Yeah. It's
it's sick again.
Describe it?
Yeah.
Fine. There we go.
Where's an error here? Terminated.
Error exit 137.
But
the image is
looks okay in cluster v one.
Nice error. Let me see.
I wish I had logs.
It's just plain error
now,
and there's nothing in describe.
Yeah. Error and crash and crash loop back.
I wonder if there's a rogue process killing
it.
Killing the
container?
Well, calendar process. They could either be in
the host or it could be in the
container.
There's no logs.
But the fact that we go
straight to exit one three seven
makes me think,
like, there's no Kubernetes events to say why
the process would be killed. It's either the
wrong image or
something that's explicitly killing the process.
Is that is that the correct image?
I mean The GCR. Is that right? At
least it's pretending it's real image. We we
don't know. It could be.
What's the pull policy?
What is the what? The image pull policy.
On this part? Let me see.
Edit part.
Always.
Policy here. Yeah. It looks okay.
So Is it always? It is always. Yeah.
Which is fine. Or there's at least we're
not getting some stale cached image with the
fake thing and the horse.
Yeah. Let's run a Yeah. P s a
u x. I'm curious if we've got something
on this machine that shouldn't be there.
PSA UX? Yeah.
Something that is running, maybe killing the container.
16.
Well, let's check the I mean, you want
to check the pods? Let me check the
pods.
Everything's running. Yeah. It should be on the
here.
Seating operator two days ago.
Because something is running XRX
off and cry control stop on the workers.
Oh,
there's a bash while true.
Oh, I'm looking at the controller port. So
I I should be looking here. Right? Yeah.
Sorry. Yeah. We've got a road process,
which is in the state of a container.
Oh, no. That's just It's running in a
CTR.
Is it as in c crawl c t
l bin? Yeah. It's running a crack control.
And that was the parent to that.
The parent to that is bash and the
parent to that is a container.
552816.
Okay. So we've got a
I can assess the emissary.
Maybe I'm reading this wrong. I'm gonna
let cat
rock
data
Head one. Okay. Let's see the system d
unit fail causing chaos.
Well, let's find it.
System d.
Yeah. Process running a show script, I guess.
Right?
Ground?
Could,
but I'm not
convinced yet.
You think so?
No. Serum service.
Sometimes reading this dataset, I just find it
too difficult.
Can we grab all the system the
definitions for
CTR?
CTL?
There's a damage. Service.
Because of the time stamp? Yeah. There we
go.
Let's card in worker two.
Worker two. Have to fix it. Yeah.
And then do you wanna delete our pod,
get it rescheduled, or mark our button, and
see what happens? Yeah. To force it there.
Let me see. Let me jump to
pods.
It pods.
Delete it. Yeah. I'm just gonna force kill
this process.
It's running now.
We have an endpoint
on
6 6 6. That's the port number for
your
Uh-huh.
App? Okay. I don't remember.
It says connection refuse.
Yeah. It's
not letting me call the service, so we're
gonna have to do it the hard way.
I was gonna p code bash, but then
realized that would be a fucking stupid idea.
There you go. Alright. Have you So that
It should be okay now.
So why why did it work before the
stop of the system b?
Because if you take a look at the
damage fail,
we have an exact stop, which also runs
command,
which James
c p.
Pointed out. Nice.
Okay. Very sneaky.
Nice.
Alright. Let's see if we have our Give
it a try again.
No. It's not
taking a while for me. Yeah. It's not
working.
Let's check network policies.
And IP tables, I guess, for the last
second.
Oops. Sorry. Okay.
I'm so invested now. I wanna know what's
going on.
That looks bad. Yeah. Yeah.
Okay. So now it's CMP and CCMPs?
I deleted I deleted it.
Just just checking. There we go.
That's the serial network policies you were checking?
I was checking the cellular network policies. Do
wanna upgrade this to V2?
Well, it's not loading. Oh, it loaded. It
loaded. Didn't load it didn't load it for
me. Okay. Now it's loaded. Okay.
So let's edit. Edit.
Deploy.
V two. I can't see that, but I'm
not gonna juggle.
You can update record version.
Hopefully,
we don't have a mutation webhook
like I was trying that
so
we bought
Dance.
Cool.
I think that's it. Do you want to
see the the hints?
Yeah. Let's see if we messed up.
Let's see.
At
hint one.
Simon says worker can sometimes be sleeping.
Okay? Yeah. That was a carton.
So request as much as you can. That
was the
memory stuff.
Three
is there's something going in the mind of
the worker. Something is super fishy. What's that
one? That was the damage system that you're
gonna fail. Okay.
And then
for
his communication
policy.
Okay. Smashed it. Well done.
Cool. Thank you.
David, for your help.
Well,
Carlos, you're an evil, evil man. But
oh, always a pleasure, and well done, team.
Just did amazingly well. There was a lot
of breaks there for you to work through
on that. So cheeky Carlos for and extra.
Starboard shredding. But good work, Carlos, working on
that cluster as well. So thank you for
joining me. It's always a pleasure.
Thank you to everyone watching. Thank you to
Teleport and Equinix Mail for their continued support,
and we'll be back next week. Any last
words, Carlos?
No.
Always follow us both on on Twitter. Right?
Definitely. I will retweet the Twitter handles after
this. Alright. Have a a great day. Thank
you, everyone, and we'll see you all again
next week for
special episode.
It's not Rawkode versus the community. It is
the community versus Rawkode.
I have two broken clusters and $400 of
Amazon vouchers to give away to anyone that
can fix them. So join us next week
live, and we'll see you then. Have a
good day. See you then.
Thank you for watching Rawkode Live.